Prof: Here we are,
talking about--recapitulating
the work done on--
in reading part of the poem,
selections of this poem.
It's a little difficult;
of course, I'm not going to
tell you exactly what we have
been talking about.
We have been reading from the
work outside of the Divine
Comedy;
we started there with the
Vita nuova,
which we read as you recall,
as a visionary text,
as a story of an education,
as an autobiography and we
tried to explore what those
terms mean and how they interact
with each other.
How does one term shed light on
the other?
What does it mean to write an
autobiography and at the same
time having an education?
The two converge,
of course, in Dante's
imagination.
You can only write an
education--a story of your
education if you have a sense of
what your whole life is about.
If you have some pattern of
coherence and intelligibility
that you can impose on,
and extract from,
respectively,
the sense of your life.
But above all,
I was interested in that
partial,
because it's sort of--it's
truncated at the end as a sort
of interruption--
deliberate interruption,
because what kind of
preparation it gives us.
To what extent is it repeated
that adventure Dante narrates in
the Vita nuova is kind of
an adumbration of the Divine
Comedy?
In many ways the two texts
really are implicating each
other in the sense that Dante
finishes the Vita nuova--
stops writing the Vita
nuova,
that's the inconclusive,
the unfinished quality of the
text so that he can go on
writing the Divine
Comedy,
if you see what I'm saying.
The Vita nuova ends with
the statement of a project,
of a project to come,
which therefore will be in a
certain way the fulfillment of
what is only hinted at in the
Vita nuova.
The two texts are literally one
is preparing for the other,
the other one--then the
Divine Comedy turns out the
way we were reading the
Divine Comedy last time.
The Divine Comedy itself
has a sort of inconclusive
quality about it.
Dante reaches and experiences
the beatific vision,
and yet his text succumbs to
the enormity of the task of
describing it,
and there were a number of
reasons why we said Dante does
that.
What seems to be,
and is, a defeat at the level
of the imagination turns out to
be a great triumph for Dante's
own theology,
right?
The measure in which that the
poem ends in a kind of defeat,
in sort of the--with the
admission of the impossibility
for Dante--
the poet's language to contain
and therefore reify,
circumscribe that which he has
seen, right?
He's sort of ending with this
question mark,
this vision of effigy as he
says, our own image.
That's all that is left for him
to recall,
which really means that--in the
refusal to pinpoint,
describe, and define the so
called beatific vision,
some people could be very
disappointed;
why doesn't he tell us what he
really saw?
Because that would be the
statement valid for him;
he wants us,
at the end of the poem to
adventure,
to take our own journey and
make our own discoveries about
that which remains the essential
point of the Divine
Comedy,
as is the essential point of
all great texts about tradition:
the encounter between the human
and the Divine.
That is the point of all the
great epics.
Whether it is in the form
the Aeneid where the hero
is always uncertain about what
the gods are telling him,
uncertain as how to decipher
it, and yet he nonetheless
pursues what he takes to be--
and makes mistakes--Aeneas,
along the way--
but what he takes to be God's
will.
This is the way he can live out
his own sense of ethical
imperative to himself,
to his people,
the refugees that are coming
from Asia Minor and going toward
an unknown land,
and the Divine imperative,
or whether it's going to be the
renaissance text from Spencer's
Fairy Queen to Tasso's,
to Milton, to Lucretius,
who writes in a theological
epic.
The idea he wants to cure his
readers,
he has one reader in mind:
the young epicurean,
and this is Lucretius,
whom Dante had never read--
he read in parts and was very
fascinated by what he read,
who wants to educate one young
man,
Manaus, a young epicurean to
the real and bitter truth of
what the epicurean philosophy
may be and that bitter truth,
the harsh truth--Lucretius
thinks that there is no such
thing.
That ours--the Roman world is a
desecrated world,
that the gods have fled,
that's the--
but that is still in the mode
of an atheist,
it is still a theological
concern because the implication
of what I'm saying is that
atheism itself may be a way of
addressing,
of course, it's a way of
addressing the question of God,
the un-knowability of God,
the distance of God,
maybe the non-existence of the
gods.
The Divine Comedy from
this point of view partakes of
this extraordinary tradition.
But he does it in a way which
is remarkably different;
Dante does his theology in a
way which is remarkably
different from anything else
that has gone on before him and,
in many ways,
after him.
I think there is a mode of
recapitulation,
this is what I have to--I will
have to briefly illustrate and
give you the chance to ask more
questions specifically about the
poem.
Some of these things that I
have said to you--the whole poem
moves towards this kind of
theology.
Condensed in Canto XXXIII of
Paradise,
recapitulated right there.
Of course Inferno goes
on talking about issues of
politics,
which is not that they are
easy, they are very complicated,
but in some ways they are
rooted in Dante's own theology.
That is, it's too easy to
believe that,
you know, this is politics,
this is theology;
they are always implicated with
one another.
In fact, sometimes the best way
to understand the theology is to
talk about the politics,
and the best way to understand
the politics is to really talk
about the theology.
They are completely,
always implicating each other.
Inferno talks about the
ethics and the politics,
Purgatorio talks about
aesthetics and ethics above all.
The possibility of
reconstructing the human beings;
so flawed they seem to be,
so incredibly sunk into the
ditches of their own
perversions, of our perversions.
How do you--so radical,
Dante's condemnation of the
political realities,
of civil war,
people cannibalizing each
other,
and not in a metaphor that man
is a wolf to man,
but literally they are doing
this.
How do you get out of it?
It's very difficult to be
so--to ostracize politics from
the possibility of the human
imagination and then at one
point saying,
well I still need this.
How are you going to make a
persuasive case for your
readers?
This was the great challenge of
Purgatorio.
We saw the question of time,
the great problem of freedom,
that all of a sudden seemed to
surface in Purgatorio
with Cato's suicide,
you remember,
with the debate about the soul,
and created freedom,
and by an act of freedom,
God's freedom to the attainment
of the free will.
Around this extraordinary
concern of freedom,
and therefore the possibilities
of the moral life,
we came to the conclusion of
Purgatorio with a garden,
the Garden of Eden,
the place of pleasures,
the place where pleasures are
not damned in and of themselves.
The question becomes now,
because that is the Sabbath,
that is the moment where
you--pleasure can be seen as the
crown of work that which crowns,
the correlation of one's own
labors and so on.
That is also rooted in theology.
Then we ended up in
Paradise where we really
talked directly,
because I think that's really
the substance of
Paradise,
the possibility of thinking of
an aesthetic theology.
How art and theology go hand in
hand,
because what joins them is the
question of--
not just the question of the
art being the temptation,
ethical temptation,
but now the question of beauty
as the mode of revelation of the
Divine.
Therefore, the implication was,
and let's hope--
I have said that very clearly,
that art becomes a way to know
God,
a way to know the Divine,
so we are moving away from
traditional assumptions about
what is the path to go and
encounter God.
What is really the discovery of
the Sacred;
is the Sacred going to be
found, some texts in Dante seems
to have believed that at some
point in a particular--
in the animation of nature,
is it going to be found in the
love that you have for your
Beatrice,
or you, or Beatrice's for your
Dante, or whatever.
He goes on thinking about these
concerns and how everything that
belongs to the world of art is
the part of the path to the
Divine.
Theology and aesthetics not
just as--well,
aesthetics as a way of making
beautiful the reality,
the theological content of
Dante's faith.
Not just that,
but--that's no longer the
question of an ornamentation.
That was the problem,
by the way, of Lucretius who at
one point says,
I wanted to write poetry
because I want to make pleasant
the bitter medicine that
Epicurus goes on administering
to you.
The way he says it,
that the gods have fled,
that there is no such a thing
as sacredness in the cosmos,
that's too bitter to bear.
I'm going to say it nicely,
now that's really--not so for
Dante.
How the actual exercise of art,
it's an ascetic exercise.
You move through art,
you refine, you think,
and you question all the
things.
It's not just an
ornamentation--ornamentation of
being the word for cosmetics,
for beautifying that which one
has--that which he will say.
These were the concerns and we
came to Canto XXXIII of
Paradise,
and I maintain to you and as
way of recapitulation,
I think I have said to you,
I hope that I have said it all
to you,
but I will gladly go over it
and I hope that if you see more
or not quite,
haven't seen what I think I've
been saying,
say it, that's really your last
chance as far as I go in this
public mode here.
The first thing that we
understand about Dante's
theology is the extraordinary
rootedness of this theology in
the human reality.
Canto XXXIII is the canto of
prayer, and we'll talk more
about the prayer as a mode of
theologizing.
Why is it a special mode of
theologizing?
The first thing is that it is a
prayer to the Virgin Mary,
that is to say a way of
thinking about how the Divine
has entered the world of history
and the human flesh.
There's no such thing as an
extraordinary--
and I think--even talking about
the cosmology of Dante I tried
to hint,
tried to say--look the physical
world and the metaphysical world
are all part of one universe.
They are two separate
hemispheres and yet there is
always a cross,
there is a chiasmus that will
connect them,
but will make them because
that's the irony of every
chiasmus.
You know what I mean by
chiasmus?
It comes from the Greek letter
chi in Greek,
that's a chiasmus,
an X, and wherever a chiasmus
you have a point of intersection
of the two arms,
but that becomes also a point
of flight.
Things come together and can be
seen to come together,
but things also seem to be
divergent, seem to be going away
from each other,
okay.
This is the cosmos of Dante;
it's an extension of what he
will say in the prayer to the
Virgin.
The human rootedness of the
Divine, not dualities,
okay, that's really a primary
item.
This will conclude,
with the idea that with the--
and makes it persuasive that
what Dante sees and remembers at
the end is our effigy,
which is clearly a throwback to
Genesis.
Let us make man in our image
and likeness,
that's what Dante will see,
but this also means that we are
in the world of images,
that Dante's own journey ends
but not in images as deceptive
appearances,
only--that which we saw the
whole of Purgatorio is
full of,
now somehow the image probably
because of our,
the shared quality of that
image becomes the locus
of the Sacred itself.
It becomes, not something that
just hides, but also reveals the
Divine.
The second thing that I think
that we have learned to
understand about this theology
of Dante is freedom.
That the foundation of Dante's
own--the foundation of his
beliefs, the foundation of his
theological beliefs,
is in freedom.
We talked about the theological
virtues,
as you recall,
the theological virtues faith,
hope, and charity:
XXIV, XXV, and XXVI with the
various examinations that Dante
goes on.
If you recall,
we were talking about the fact
that Dante thinks of faith as an
act of freedom.
That's not unusual for those
who have any theological
interest to even find traces and
implications of this kind of
statement.
Faith is, for Dante,
a way of knowing;
he connects it with knowledge,
which is not just a way of
saying that faith intervenes
when knowledge stops because
someone who is interested in his
curiosity of knowing--
now I don't know I'll try hard,
maybe tomorrow I will know,
I don't need any faith, right?
If you really think about the
relationship between knowledge
and faith,
you can't say faith emerges at
the boundary line of knowledge
because that boundary line is
always shifting,
and that would imply the
progressive reduction of a kind
of receding,
and diminishing fragment of the
dimension of faith.
Dante's saying by connecting a
university examination and the
problem of faith is that faith
itself is a way of knowing I
have faith,
and that means that I see the
world in an entirely different
way;
I can see myself disengaged
from everything around me.
I can see that nothing really
matters;
that all the patterns and
parameters of reasons are going
to be found wanting.
That's really--so it's tied
with freedom.
Hope introduces the question of
the future, and you cannot have
freedom without the future.
We talked about these temporal
issues.
You can only think about the
possibility of a future if you
believe that it is a novelty,
if there is a freedom--if you
are in bondage you cannot really
think of that.
Theologically,
because I don't want to confuse
you at all, you remember that
all three cantos were literally
woven with references to Exodus.
All three cantos and the story
of Exodus, which is crucial to
Dante's poetic figuration,
is the story of the freedom
from a state of bondage.
This is the way we understand
him, but Dante also knows that
freedom can--you only have to
shift--this is Luther of course;
freedom and faith are one in
the same thing.
In his attack--you remember
that?
I mentioned this to you,
it doesn't concern Dante but
concerns the issue and so we'll
mention for clarity.
They debated,
the two of them,
Luther and Erasmus over the
idea of what freedom of the will
means,
and they are really debating a
text written a century earlier
by one humanist by the name of
Valla and they disagree about
what that text means.
Luther says to Erasmus,
you really are interested in
faith as a form of order.
I'm interested in faith as a
form of freedom because that
frees me from all loyalties.
It's madness by the sublime
quality of the statement,
but you only have to shift the
ground a little bit and realize
that freedom,
can really become,
and is the source of atheism.
Atheism, all of a sudden,
becomes important because human
beings don't want to be
subjected to anybody.
It's part of the project to say
I am my own man,
I am my own woman,
I want to do exactly what I
want.
I don't want to have any
loyalties or accept anything
that I don't even see.
We can bear with the master
that we see and maybe has a
knife at us,
but someone as distant and
remote we--
Dante then says that's the
peculiarity of this religious
belief of mine,
which is really all about
freedom, including the freedom
to deny the divinity.
This is extraordinary,
never heard of in the history
of--as far as I know and I have
a very limited knowledge believe
me, it's no rhetoric;
very limited knowledge but I
have never seen anything like
this.
The third element about this
theology is really the great
element of love,
to discover that the way to
God, yes it's hard;
there are many ways first of
all to God.
There is the philosophical of
going through knowing,
there is the linguistic way
through the language,
and I'll come to this issue in
a moment.
There is poetry,
there is the world of beauty,
then there's the language of
the heart, but primarily it is
the path to the Divine is love.
Dante understands,
I wasn't saying that love is so
mysterious because I know that
deep down you are all young
people,
many of you are,
a couple here are younger,
much younger than I am but not
really that young,
so they are not surprised by
any this.
But I know that deep down,
I remember being young,
how I think about the mystery
of love,
ah… that really speaks
to everybody's heart.
I wasn't meaning it that way.
It is really a thought point
that the principle of election,
which is so crucial to love,
it really cannot be quite
explained.
I really was meaning it in this
theological way as possible.
I was already thinking about
the statements that I was going
to make today about Dante's
theology.
These are some of the issues
that Dante has.
The other day,
yesterday, the day before I was
asked the question about one
line in Dante and I was very--
it was a very good question
about the fact that Dante's
allowed to see the truth,
that the light he saw was the
truth.
That was a very good question.
What does it mean?
To me it was so clear,
and I apologize,
because I said well this is
really the biblical idea in your
light, which your notes will
tell you.
In your light I see the light,
we see the light,
and what does it mean?
In your light we see the light.
What it is that it's part of
this mystery that if you are a
mystic and you think that the
Divine is wrapped in a kind of
transcendent darkness,
that's the language,
or that it is really all
wrapped in impenetrable light,
it's both the same because
neither light has the
peculiarity never letting you
see the origin of the light,
and darkness has the
peculiarity of never letting you
see the origin of the darkness.
When Dante reaches
Paradiso XXXIII,
and that's the meaning your
light, we see the light,
Dante sees finally the origin
of light.
That's the point.
There are moments where his
sight can become so incredibly
sharp and so penetrating,
so look at all these ways.
The ways--there are many ways
in which we can take available
to us and it seems that we are
always stumbling against
something that in the long run
you have to stop,
and yet if you love,
if you think that beauty is
part--
which is part of love,
beauty is part of--
love is the hunger for beauty
the neo-Platonist will say.
In the Florentine neo-Platonist
Lorenzo--I don't know where he
found it probably in Plotinus;
love is the hunger for beauty.
All of these are ways that
Dante keeps opening for us in
our journey to the Divine,
and then there is the prayer
which is the question of
language.
That has also become one of the
ways in which I indicate that
there is a theological root to
the question of language.
Not only that we speak out of
speaking and language is an
allegory,
a parable of our desires,
a parable of what we lack,
we speak because we don't have.
That's the specific--and we
speak because we--the seat mate
and we are pointing maybe
without really knowing to what
we need.
It's always a question of need.
Dante has always had a way of
connecting language and desire,
we talked about that,
that's one the themes we
discussed.
Then all of a sudden in
Paradiso XXXIII,
though I said to you,
look the language now changes.
First of all,
the prayer to the Virgin is all
about longing,
this state of longing but not
languishing.
There is an etymological
connection there somewhere which
is not--
I'm not going to get into but
there's a longing for the Divine
to show itself to Bernard of
Clairvaux, the great mystic.
He who is the great fierce
opponent of Abelard,
appears on the scene and
therefore they--
you can overhear the polemics
which we haven't got time for,
the polemics between Abelard
and Bernard that are clearly
behind his apparition in
Paradiso XXXIII.
They all are waiting for the
Divine to show itself forth,
right, and this language--and
yet this desire all of a sudden
becomes the language of joy,
of enjoyment.
That's such an extraordinary
shift.
Why?
Because Dante understands the
problem with desire;
of course, we like to--we're
always talking about how much--
how permanent we like to be,
in a state of permanent desires
because that's what makes us
feel alive,
young, to desire,
you want something.
It's true, it's part of the
great power of desire,
and the language of desire,
but if desire were without an
object ever then desire becomes
of the greatest absurdity and
futility.
If we go around thinking that
we are in a labyrinth of desires
then really that is--it's a
joke, desire becomes a joke.
Dante places this idea of
enjoyment, the possibility of
this sweetness that instills in
his heart.
These are the issues.
Then finally,
this idea of prayer,
and I want to stop there.
Let me stop with the question
of prayer and then get your
questions.
The whole poem,
I think, from the perspective
of Paradiso XXXIII,
taking retrospectively the
view, not only the fact that
there are references to the
first words Dante uses in
Inferno I is a prayer.
"Miserere di
me,"
"Have mercy on me,"
he doesn't even know whether
you are a shade or a man,
he sees something,
a shape indistinct,
turns out to be Virgil,
turns out to be poetry.
This is the poetry that lends
itself, offers itself completely
freely.
You can go to the library and
pick up a book,
a free act of someone's
generosity.
There it is.
He turns to it and begins with
a prayer,
and the poem ends with a
prayer, and ends with--
it begins with a prayer--the
whole poem,
the real quality and nature of
language is to be a prayer.
A prayer implying the tension
that we have all the time told
what, for Dante,
told what necessarily
transcends us.
There's always a reality that
is touched directly by the hand
of God, but escapes the world of
the human plans,
and the human projects.
This is what I think the whole
poem is about,
and it's above all a poem
addressed to the future,
addressed to us.
That is to say,
it's not a poem about the past,
Dante is the least nostalgic of
poets,
it's so easy,
if you really go wherever and
you tell your grandchildren you
read Dante.
I thought that Dante is a nice
little story about the Middle
Ages;
we are all nostalgic about the
Middle Ages.
Maybe some of you are here--how
were these guys,
how were they living?
In a world of absolute
certainties, right?
Dante is the poet of openness,
the poet who understands
reason, and understands the
risk.
Now, that's really what this
poem is about,
a poem about the future,
the poem addressed with a
number of apostrophes to
readers,
and whenever you read
apostrophe to readers from
beginning of Inferno to
roughly Paradiso X,
every so often Dante addresses
us.
You remember I said,
at one point he stops,
he made this point,
what are these addresses to
readers?
We can read it--whenever you
have a kind of--
up to the eighteenth century
you always read novels,
now my dear reader,
now my gentle reader,
they are coaxing you,
pretending they're coaxing you,
they couldn't care whether you
read it or not I don't think
ultimately.
Dante doesn't really care
whether we are reading him or
not.
Now you're following the little
shape of poetry,
the few of you,
and I think he means it,
who are not afraid of how rough
the seas are.
You could shipwreck and all of
that--
of course you could read those
apostrophes as a way of saying,
look I need you readers because
if I have readers I'm
constituting myself into an
author.
The measure in which there are
readers, then I am the author,
I am an author because I
have--because the poem has made
me into an author.
Of course there is that,
but what I think this is about
is you are going to use my poem
as the boat with which you can
start your own journey.
That's the understanding of the
future.
The poet, Dante,
is a poet of the future,
which is a way of saying there
is a little bit of irony as I
say this,
that Dante's not a poet of the
past,
he is the poet toward which we
are going.
The Middle Ages may not be a
time of the past,
it may be the Middle ages in a
different form or certainly will
come back,
will probably come back in the
future.
This is what Dante clearly
thinks.
So let's go now with your
questions.
I hope you have many and--not
many, a few so that we can talk
a bit about this.
Yes, whoever wants to--you came
in late so I must say--
must repeat this--you have to
sign and there is that beautiful
young woman right there,
Maria Derlipanska,
that adjective,
you forgive me but it's true
but also--
the other thing is you have to
talk very closely to the
microphone.
Student:  Well,
I wanted to talk a little bit
more about desire and I'm glad
you brought that up because it's
been on my mind for the last
couple of days.
I was just reading
Shakespeare's 147^(th) sonnet
yesterday in which he says,
"desire is death,"
and it struck me how different
Dante's inception of desire is
and it's something that he seems
to want to stay in and relish
and it's almost life to him.
We started this course with the
Vita nuova and I got so
frustrated reading it because
I--
part of me was saying if you
love this woman so much why
don't you do something about it?
But it's like Dante no,
he wants to stay in this place
of longing;
longing is life for him in some
way.
That seems to me something
vitally important to
understanding what the Divine
Comedy means and I wonder if
you could just go back and talk
a little bit about the courtly
love tradition,
how that might have influenced
Dante's thinking about desire,
and more specifically,
in a spiritual sense as to
Dante's theology,
how desire played a role in
Dante's conception of his
relationship to God?
Prof: Yes, okay.
Well good question.
I like the fact that you bring
in, I will take the points as I
remember them,
but also following at my own
inner logic.
I like the way you bring in
Shakespeare's understanding of
desire and that desire--
it's not that it's really death
but ends in death,
that the desire leads you to
death.
That this is a kind of--that is
in many ways also a view largely
shared by Dante in this sense,
but it's not only that,
Dante does not stop there.
In this sense that you have to
understand that there's such a
thing as a metaphysics of
desire.
I don't know if the term is new
to you or not.
What could that phrase possibly
mean?
Why do we talk--what does it
Metaphysics of desire,
to some of you,
it may be a little bit unusual,
it really means this,
that desire--there is a
dialectics to desire,
a movement to desire that
necessarily I want this today
then I want that,
the desire is inexhaustible,
that's what it means.
From that point of view it's
very important for all those
like Augustine,
it's part of this restlessness
of the heart as St.
Augustine mentions.
That's the--a theological
understanding of desire.
We call it metaphysical because
it really wants the absolutes.
Desire, by definition,
I want now this,
the smoking of a cigarette for
a great novelist,
an Italian novelist at the
beginning of the last century
was the true emblem of desire,
ending in ashes but always like
a phoenix you can start over
again.
It really means that it
always--it will come to an end
either in death,
in nothingness;
finally you renounce all desire
which is the death of desire or
some idea of the absolute of
God.
That's really--that's what we
mean by the absolute--this
absolute tension that desire
entails.
Now then you asked me to talk
about the Vita nuova and
the uneasiness you had.
I mean, you expressed the
uneasiness and I respect your
uneasiness.
I know a man of action like
you, a student of philosophy as
you are, then you obviously have
that kind--I think that you're
supposed to have that.
There is such a thing as a
passivity of the state of
dejection,
the sense of the mastery of
love that throws the lover poet
into--
who doesn't really understand
what love is at this point,
that's what part of the
education is.
He wants to--the story of the
Vita nuova is the story
of a poet who knows--
he doesn't know Beatrice,
he calls her Beatrice only
because in the nearness of her
he would feel beatitudes;
that's what he says,
so there's a kind of
arbitrariness to names.
We don't care about that now,
we go on with--there is this
idea that he is--the power of
love dejects him.
It's not yet a virtue,
it's a passion,
and the word passion really
implies that.
We think that a passion is what
makes us go but Dante makes a
careful distinction of the will
that becomes paralyzed,
the desire to be discovered by
the woman he loves.
It's very important for him
that she says "hi"
when they meet in the streets
and he--
she won't say "hi"
and so he goes home and he's
dejected and says I'm worthless,
etc.
That is--he's explaining the
kind of--that sort of state of
dejection that love can bring
in--or the passion of love can
bring into the mind.
The mind is clouded,
unable to think straight but
that--for him also sheds light
on the way he understands poetry
because he waits for poetry.
He's a sort of poet,
very romantic poet,
who doesn't think that poetry
entails discipline.
It's almost like somebody else
says,
it's almost like going to the
office at 7:00 a.m.,
you sit down at the desk,
and keep at it,
and then maybe you'll manage to
come up with a great line.
He hopes for--romantically for
poetry to come to him,
for inspiration to come to him,
and then he realizes that his
understanding of love was as
wrong as his--
of the love passion was as
wrong as his understanding of
poetry,
that you've got to really get
down and do something about it.
When he understands it,
it's too late for him,
because Beatrice has died,
so now the poem--
the project of the Divine
Comedy--
she may be--he has a vision,
he sees her at the foot of
God's majesty and says I want to
go there an meet with her,
that's action.
You agree that that really is
quite--has completely changed.
How does this understanding of
love connect with the courtly
love tradition?
That is really not a difficult
question.
In fact I would give you a
little bit of a bibliography
that C.S. Lewis has written a
very good book on The
Allegory of Love,
a book written probably in the
late 50s,
but last time I read it which
was recently some twenty years
ago,
it was still very good,
very powerful.
The idea is this that--and I'm
really paraphrasing C.S. Lewis
more or less,
I mean with a lot of gaps in my
mind about the richness of the
text.
That clearly what we think of
love today as a romantic
understanding,
it's really a discovery of the
Middle Ages.
I have been talking about the
fact that, you may all recall,
the Greeks did not have this
romantic understanding.
The Romans didn't have this
understanding of love.
When you read Catullus,
the passion for a woman is
something that he's always a
little uneasy about.
That's not what a virtuous man
should be doing.
It's a weakness of the will.
The weakness of the will,
it's a vice,
what can you do,
we are fallible--we are Romans
but we are also occasionally a
little fallible.
The idea of romantic love comes
with Provencal poets in the
south of France,
what you call courtly love.
I would distinguish that,
that's all, the only thing I
would say about it.
You don't read the C.S. Lewis
who ends up with love and the
history of love in the--how it
changes, that is to say,
in the Renaissance.
I would distinguish between the
two;
I would not use
indiscriminately courtly love
and medieval ideas of love.
Courtly love implies a
formalization of love and it
goes back--
some of you I know are writing
a paper on this,
on Andreas Capellanus,
The Art of Courtly Love,
which is a way of setting rules
for loves,
in the perception that love is
a potentially disruptive
experience and so let us make it
into a joke,
that's the idea.
Let us establish protocols,
a code by means of which the
woman and the man can really
interact and tell each other
what this is about.
Don't hope marriage because
that's a serious business
concerning property,
and wealth, and status so
within the fairly close
boundaries of the courtly love
tradition,
then you go on making such
assumptions about yourself
about--
you can play about the
greatness of women,
the secret of love,
there's a certain code.
In the other forms of courtly
love, or the sweet new style,
and the way it develops.
Another book I could mention to
you is Valency which is love
something--
I can't even remember the
title, Maurice Valency,
he also discusses the shifts
between Provencal understanding
of love and the sweet new style
articulated by Dante and his
coterie of poets.
That makes it I hope.
Student:  Thank you for
an extraordinary series of
lectures.
I was curious about the ending
and I wondered if you could
comment on Dante's views about
the papacy?
I thought his choice of Bernard
of Clairvaux was very curious
and throughout the Divine
Comedy he previously was
grumbling about papal
intervention over temporal
powers,
so I wondered if you could
comment on that conclusion.
Prof: Yeah,
very good question.
Of course I didn't talk about
it, and I think that what you're
really referring to,
I don't know,
but I think what you're
referring to is the fact that
Bernard of Clairvaux wrote a
great book called,
On Consideration,
which seems to be about
contemplative life.
He's the great reformer of the
Benedictine movement,
monastic movement in France,
and the so called Cistercian
monasteries which became the
centers of culture where they
would copy--
they would do poetry,
they would write music,
they would sing.
I mean the arts,
the way we know them,
really originated with him.
He wrote this text On
Consideration which
actually,
in spite of the title,
because you know what
consideration is a step before
you come to contemplation.
There are a number--reflection,
consideration,
and then contemplation.
He chooses to write on
consideration.
He dedicates the book to--this
treatise to Pope Eugene IV who
had been his disciple,
he had been a--a Frenchman who
had been a Benedictine monk with
him and it's--
and this is probably one reason
why Dante chooses Bernard.
Bernard, the contemplative
monk, the reformer,
all of Paradise is
populated with founders and
great reformers,
founders of orders or Justinian
and the law, etc.
France is Benedict,
Dominic, Bernard and so in
spite of the fact that he's a
contemplative,
Bernard did not hesitate to
write a text for the spiritual
edification of his ex-disciple,
Eugene the IV,
who is now a Pope and he's
aware how the office of the
shepherd of the church can
distract him from the loftier
spiritual aims and the longings,
so it's really a sequence of
arguments about what you
should--
how should you administer your
time so that you are never
really going to lose sight of
what your true aim is,
Heaven.
Dante mentions this text,
by the way,
in a letter that so many--not
I, go on challenging the
authority of,
the letter to Cangrande that
maybe I have--
no not with you,
with my graduate students we
have gone over,
but to me that is actually the
indication,
the fact that he refers to the
treatise by Bernard that the
authority of--
he is the author of that letter.
Now, you see it clearly another
way in which I can understand
your question is that you see
some kind of divergence,
some sort of break.
On the one hand this kind of
invective, the mode of the
invective in Dante when talking
about Peter, St.
Peter in Paradiso XXVII.
I mean, he doesn't--he looks
back after the examination on
faith,
he looks back and he starts
attacking what he takes to be
the use of patience,
my place;
remember that,
an incredibly moral voice that
rises right at the very end.
You seem to be worried about
the fact that Dante seems to be
so moral and--
when it comes about the popes
and then becomes mystical all of
a sudden,
is that really one of your
concerns?
It could be,
it could become one of your
concerns in asking this question
about--
at the end of Paradise
XXXIII he talks about Bernard
such a mystic and yet all over
he has been talking about the
papacy.
If you were interested in that
I would say there is no
divergence in Dante between the
prophetic voice and the mystical
voice.
That is something--even those
who read the Bible would go on
saying, well,
the prophets were visionaries.
In a way it's true but in a way
it's not true,
the prophets were not
visionaries, the prophets were
readers of history.
They don't need to have Daniel
give an interpretation;
Ezekiel has visions,
but Isaiah doesn't have visions
so it's--you see what I'm
saying?
There is no clear-cut
distinction between the
prophetic and the mystical,
certainly not in Dante.
The two belong together so
that's--I don't know that I'm
answering your concerns but I
overheard a number of let's say
rumblings in your question.
I'm trying to take care of them.
Student:  Is it a
reconciliation with the papacy?
Prof: No,
not in the sense--no.
To talk about--even Bernard is
someone who understands how
waylaying the office can be and
he was obviously writing because
he must be aware of what has
been happening and what was
likely to happen.
You don't have to become a
chronicler or an historian to do
that;
you can imagine this can happen.
No, there is not that.
I think that's Dante's judgment
about history is always very
clear until the very end.
History needs a reform and of
course he would say,
because he's one who believes
in the sacramentality and
presence of the self,
how the self is crucial--before
I start talking about how the
world needs reforming let me
just begin here.
That would be an obvious way to
say it,
so I call it the language of
presence in him,
a sense of, I am present to my
own self and therefore I have
responsibilities toward my own
self before I became--
I started using the megaphones
and let's reform the world.
That probably--if there were
ever to come and Dante's not a
utopian thinker,
it would come only because so
many people of good will,
men and women of good will,
his saints,
his blessed--the blessed souls
that he meets are willing to do
something about that.
No, no reconciliation,
not a sense of finally things
will be becoming together,
I don't think.
Actually I hold onto that.
Student:  Just thinking
more about desire and wealth and
the fact that the will is what
loves and the will always
contains some element of lack,
or desire it seems,
so even if it can attain
plentitude it still seems that
Dante in talking so much about
the will and the will as loving,
Dante says that love always has
some element of lack.
It's not just lack,
there is plentitude,
but still there's always this
restlessness and so the love at
the end where there is
plentitude it seems to be a
completely transformed
understanding of love,
that it's not possible to
go--to return from in the
beatific vision.
If you have this plentitude,
is it possible to go back
because it does seem like it's a
completely transformed
understanding of love when you
have just the plentitude and not
lack anymore so with that mind
does--
is Dante ever able to attain
this love because this love that
does have plentitude seems like
it should end in silence with no
language and Dante does go back
and speak,
and he does--he is still--he is
a pilgrim and a poet and so does
he really ever move from the
images to the essences and is
the uncertainty at the end not
just because we have to go on
the journey our self but because
he is still on the journey?
Prof: Well,
you are really voicing a very
delicate issue in the poem.
It's a very controversial issue
because that also implies the
status of the poem.
Do you understand what I'm
saying?
In other words,
if you really think that Dante
has seen--
has had a beatific vision and
he has,
and now he's writing the poem
to tell us about it,
then you're really saying that
the poem itself belongs to a
higher level of experience
because it's written by someone
who is in full possession of
grace.
That's your point, right?
That's a very delicate point
because I have not been teaching
Dante that way,
right, I have not.
We are right to say this,
at the moment of
recapitulation,
I probably would--I have wasted
your time all along.
One little detail that I want
to bring to your attention and
then I will go to the more
general problem;
when Dante meets Beatrice in
Purgatorio XXXI,
this is getting really to be a
recapitulation,
we're talking about everything
in the poem now,
he meets Beatrice in
Purgatorio XXX and then
in XXXI.
In Purgatorio XXXI
Beatrice forces Dante to go into
a confession.
You have to go into an
admission of who you are,
and has to be public;
cannot say I know you know,
but you have to be duly ashamed
because only that way you can
transcend whatever it is that
you have within you.
Dante reluctantly will agree to
do that and then Beatrice will
say,
I want you to go through this
so that another time,
the future tense,
when you will see,
will meet the siren I want you
to be stronger.
This to me implies,
that's one of the many--Dante
sees Casella,
another aesthetic temptation.
One doesn't have to have the
temptation to kill someone,
to really feel that what is
out--has fallen out of grace but
this is--
he meets Casella and he
remembers how sweet was that
song he heard from Casella and
that sweetness still resounds
within me.
Now Dante is writing--is
talking as a poet--he meets
Ulysses, I grieve then and I
grieve now.
There is a way in which states
within the pilgrim do not really
go on changing;
they are the same,
implying that there is some
kind of continuity between
pilgrimage and poetry writing.
To me, the writing of poetry is
an extension of the pilgrimage.
Dante though goes on saying;
I have had the beatific vision.
I am now--I know what enjoyment
means,
not just desire,
but I'm coming back to the
Earth and therefore I cannot
come back to the Earth as
anything less than a human being
with one project,
the project to write a poem,
because I want to retrieve that
joy and because I want to share
that joy.
So I have set down two things
in my answer to you.
One talking about the question
of the pilgrim's experience and
the relationship of the
pilgrim's experience to the
writing of a poem,
but I have also said that the
poem stands as a sign for us.
A hermeneutical moment;
Dante means it for us so that
we can--his journey continues.
That's my answer.
You don't have to agree with it
because there are--
I know there is--there are
other people,
I have been fighting those
people for a long time in my
life,
I don't want to go back to
those fights,
but I think that that this my
way of looking at it,
okay.
I can give you more
bibliography;
I would rather not actually,
to tell you the truth.
I don't want to tell you about
those people who are writing the
other way.
I have written about them in my
books.
Student:  I was
wondering if you could talk a
little bit more about how Dante
views other religions.
In particular,
Judaism and if it sort of falls
underneath his idea of religion
as freedom,
and that if you have the
freedom to become an atheist you
also have the freedom to choose
a different religion and if he
views Judaism and Christianity
as sort of a continuity both
deriving from the same basis or
if he ascribes the idea of
secessionism that Christianity
has succeeded Judaism and
invalidates it,
and for that reason we don't
find, from what I can remember,
and Jews in Paradise.
Prof: Oh yes you do.
Student:  You do?
Okay then that's my fault.
Prof: Well,
now I have to correct you
immediately because then maybe
you rephrase it--
stay there--because you
probably will rephrase the
question.
When Dante goes on listing,
in the mystical rose,
we even are told that Beatrice
sits next to Rachel.
She has a way of elevating her
and then he goes on describing
all the other--we talked at
length about Solomon who is a
Jew, I think right?
He was a Jew in the Bible.
We went on talking about
Nathan, I tried to make light of
it because I wanted to tell you
that Dante saw his own name but
it's Nathan,
a prophet of David,
and also in the harrowing of
hell which is Inferno IV,
where Dante describes what
happens to Jesus after his
death,
what does he do?
He harrows hell.
He goes into hell.
What is he doing in hell?
He goes there to take the
patriarchs and the women of
Israel and take them to heaven.
That's--these are facts--you
want to change your question or
I can go on telling you more and
answering the real questions
that you are raising,
that is to say the relationship
between Christianity and Judaism
and the other religions.
You want me to talk about that?
Student:  That's
definitely the issue that I
have.
Whether Dante--I guess like I
said before,
I guess by having Jews in
Paradise and having the
figure of Christ come in and
collect the patriarchs,
if he's trying to integrate
Judaism within Christianity or
somehow to find a way between
the two?
Prof: Yes.
That is--so you're interested
especially about Dante's sense
of--the relationship between
Christianity and Judaism?
Do you want me to also address
the other issue of the way he
looks at the Hindus and the
Muslims?
We talked about Dante and the
other religions.
In fact, when I--when we talked
about Dante's relationship with
a sense of Christianity to the
other religions,
I never mentioned the Jews and
probably that to you may have
been a kind of glaring omission.
This guy is talking about the
big religions,
what about the matriarchs of
the religions?
The Judaism--it's likely--I
occasionally thought maybe I
should say something,
and then I said no because
Dante doesn't talk about it and
so I wouldn't.
Dante does talk when he
has--and he is not the only one,
centuries before him they were
talking--
a man like--a great theologian
by the name of Bonaventure,
a professor of theology at the
University of Paris.
I mentioned that text I'm sure,
and the year 1274 which is also
the year of his death,
he was invited to Paris,
he was teaching there,
because he was invited to
deliver a number of lectures and
he gives these lectures,
and then he goes on talking
about the other religions,
the religions he knows:
Hindu and the Muslim religion.
It's an argument--I mention
that because it seems to me that
Dante follows Bonaventure fairly
closely when in the canto of St.
Francis, Canto X,
the description of the--that
legend of St.
Francis, Francis is said to
have gone to the sultan to try
to convert him and fails,
and then Dante also talks of
the Hindus,
with the reference to the
Ganges.
When talking about justice,
Dante is talking about Europe,
but in between he alludes to
the--he talks about the Persians
and the Hindu,
the guy from the Hin who is
born on the river Hindus,
he says you are of the Hindus.
What is the conception there?
The critique,
they are talking as Christians
and they are talking from the
point of view of Christianity.
The position that Bonaventure
will have, and Dante I think
follows him, is the following.
How does it--how it can be--can
they be distinguished?
What do they share?
They talk about what they share.
What do they have in common?
They have in common,
especially with the case of the
Muslims, the biblical--the
Jewish tradition.
Let me just not mince words
here, the Jewish tradition,
that's really the common matrix
for him.
He also notices differences,
that for instance,
the theology of the Hindus is
one that presumes the
diffusiveness of God into all
things.
That's not--I don't think
that's something that unusual.
What does it imply?
Because they become critical of
it, it then implies the
difficulty of making judgments
about what's good and evil.
If God is everywhere you have
to--the sacrality of all things,
which is a great idea,
and yet there are some aspects
of reality where you don't like
to think that they are all
alike.
There is a way in which--this
is pantheism and can become--
therefore can become--can be
critiqued as the lack of
distinctions and hierarchies,
and ordering.
When they come to the Muslims,
since the Muslim religion is
one that talks about the
absolute impenetrability of the
human mind cannot ever hope to
understand the Divine.
We are here at the mercy of God
and we live only by the mercy of
God.
We cannot go on and say,
but I live by reason and I die
by reason, and I can get to know
God.
There is a great distance
between the human and the
Divine.
That's the critique.
If this is true then we have
nothing to--
there is an absolute
transcendence and he sees
Christianity as that which
literally mediates between the
two because there is that
transcendence and absolute
transcendence of God,
the way the Muslims understand
it, but there is also a
possibility of a mediation.
Not total mediation the way the
Hindus understand it,
but the mediation of the cross,
the mediation of the
incarnation.
This is the way Dante takes the
other religions.
When it comes to the pagan
religions,
not because they are the pagan
religions for instance,
and Dante there follows very
much the pagan religion,
the religion of the Greeks,
the religion of the Romans.
Dante follows very much St.
Augustine, who is the one who
talks at length about these
issues.
That's the ambiguity;
there are adumbrations of the
Divine, but at the same time,
they can become also
blasphemous idols of the
infernal powers.
There is this way of really the
smashing, if you wish,
of the idols.
When it comes to Judaism,
which is really the question
that--with which you started
actually.
I think that Dante is--I talked
about that.
I shouldn't say that I didn't
talk about it.
You may recall that I made a
point in--
at the beginning of the
readings of the poem,
maybe I was not--it didn't seem
to be very important,
it was important to me;
I sort of went on talking a
little bit at length about the
question of birth.
You remember how there are some
characters, representations,
all characters?
Dante continues,
I could have said the same
thing in the prayer to the
Virgin;
Virgin, mother,
daughter of your son;
two birds in one stone,
in half a line as it were.
Daughter of your son,
Dante focuses on birth.
I did say, I went on talking
since--
Dante talks like this about
Virgil,
then talks about the birth of
Francesca,
Giacco in Canto VI,
Farinata in Canto X,
endlessly talks about this
whole issue.
Then I went on talking,
this concern with birth is
specifically Roman,
I said.
This is really a Roman insight
into the importance--it's really
what distinguishes the Greek
tragic understanding of birth.
Children can really become a
curse in--
when you read the
Thebaid, for instance,
where you read the story of
Oedipus,
with Statius being half Greek,
sort of incorporates.
Then I added,
after saying that this a Roman
concern, because it's the
whole--it's tied to the notion
of foundation.
The Roman idea that you can
start things over and over again
with the foundations of cities
and the birth being the way in
which nature becomes historical,
and therefore,
I potentially like all of you
potentially can change
everything around you.
It's not true,
as someone at a round table the
other night in my department,
was saying that you have no
experience, there are no events.
Of course there are experiences
and events,
every birth is an event,
that's Dante's understanding
because he can change history,
he can change the future.
After making these statements
that that's a Roman idea,
and or Dante that's crucial
because he's a Roman,
and he thinks of himself as a
Roman;
Florence is the daughter of
Rome.
Then I added that this is also
a Jewish idea of creation.
That that's really what we
have, mainly the great invention
that we have in the Bible,
that the world was created and
that Dante is connecting two
ideas,
a Roman and a Jewish idea,
which are miraculously
convergent.
Is this an act of useful
patience because that's really
the--what I read in your
question.
Is that an appropriation?
It's culture.
I think that that's really what
you do, but you can say that
about the Bible.
You read, the Bible is a
reading of history,
over 800 years of its
composition.
It's a reading of events around
them and the culture,
and that's exactly what Dante
does.
How does he look at--he thinks
that the Jews--
I guess he's really saying they
are not Christians but they
believe in a Christ to come and
that will save them.
This really means that there is
an acknowledgement of the
dignity and certainly
originality of that vision.
I answered clearly;
you may agree,
you may not agree,
but it's clear.
We agree about that.
Student:  I was
wondering if you could just
brief--
I was wondering if you could
discuss the presence of violence
in all of these texts that we've
been reading.
I'm thinking particularly about
the Vita nuova and the
depiction of violence in these
dreams filled with passion and
very strange representations of
the color red and all--
as both a lustful color,
the fear of death in these
depictions of love which reminds
me of courtly love and this idea
that our passions are sort of
transcendental violent dreams,
and images that come to us.
That's one question,
one part, but the other is the
presence of violence and violent
imagery in Paradiso,
I'm thinking particularly about
marshes at the beginning in
Canto I?
Also, the implied moral
violation of Piccarda and these
continuous images that remind us
of human violence and passion as
violence,
and I wonder how they fit in
with the final vision of
beatitude and human love?
Prof: That brings us
right back to the relationship
between the historical and the
sacred.
Violence is a parody almost of
the sacred,
and in many ways,
the alibi for the sacred
because the sacred has to be
understood as that which tries
to redeem the violence.
And Dante, you're absolutely
right, never flinches from the
understanding that the world of
history is an economy of this
ongoing violence.
It's true.
He even addresses you, right.
The human beings,
the Cato who kills himself
hoping that with his death he
can bring an end to the civil
war in Rome between Caesar and
Pompeii,
but then the violence
that--someone like Piccarda.
How love engenders violence,
it's an incredibly thing,
because then they have
perversions.
It's not just that I killed
because I want to steal
someone's shoes,
but then there is a way in
which I think I'm engaged a more
tragic understanding of violence
because a sort it--
it's so mediated and so
disguised as love.
I can love, from Paolo and
Francesca, and yet that
engenders a lot of violence.
Dante has gone through all the
phases for this sort of
thinking.
That of thinking that maybe
that's really what history is
about;
it's all about violence and
that any effort at redemption,
Christ's redemption of
violence, that's really what the
whole story of Christian
salvation is about.
Dante mentions that,
this is not a kind of an
opinion, Dante will mention it
in Inferno XXXIII.
Remember, with the story of
Ugolino,
in the background of that
scene, of that famous
cannibalizing,
that is the story of the
children have been killed,
two of his children,
and that's always the death of
the innocent is really the
beginning--
what happens to the children?
We can go on arguing but what
about these kids?
We have no response of what is
innocent as Dante says,
and then you overhear in the
background,
and I think that Dante wants us
to overhear the experience of
the cross that was meant to
redeem of violence but didn't
seem to work,
so there is a way in which he
thinks violence has--
to the notion and to the god of
violence,
even the redemption succumbs to
that vision.
The idea of redemption loses in
connection with--and in relation
to violence.
That would be the way we can
come to understand it.
There are a number of other
extensions,
even when we read Dante will
say, when we read,
it seems to be such an
innocuous bland operation that
we're engaged in,
in the quiet of our studies,
etc., then we are still
violating the integrity of the
text.
We still extract,
we still break up that unity,
we isolate the passage,
we make part of what we want,
what we want it to signify,
hermeneutics is linked,
interpretation is linked to an
experience of violence.
What gives?
We agree there,
that was your question,
how does Dante get beyond that
and somehow manage to arrive to
a beatific vision?
I think that what Dante is
doing is denouncing all forms of
violence, confessing to them,
admitting them,
dramatizing them.
It doesn't mean that he's
espousing them or he shares
them,
the whole point of the
Divine Comedy is to
acknowledge that it lodges --
it, violence -- lodges even in
him and within him,
but he wants to move beyond it
and that's the ascetic aspect of
his text,
ascetic in the sense that he's
literally climbing up the ladder
of transcending that which is
holding him back.
I don't think that--if you are
looking for way that--does he
get away from it?
That's really the other
question, does he ever get away?
Not in the measure in which
he's human and wants to remain
human, open to these temptations
all the time.
Please.
Student:  As a pilgrim
who has become a senior citizen
I have had a question throughout
the entire course,
and having read Auerbach and
Thomas Bergen and Mary Reynolds
and others,
the question has not been
answered for me and I'm not sure
you can either.
The question is who is Dante?
As we've been responding to
these--you've been responding to
these questions here,
I've jotted down human,
man, citizen,
exile, lover,
poet, pilgrim,
visionary,
theologian, saint,
Paul, Teresa of Avila,
John of the Cross,
Bernard of Clairvaux had their
visions and they became saints.
Is this man a saint?
Prof: Well,
I'm taking a little bit of time
to answer because you must know;
I think you know that actually
there are people who think that
he should be canonized.
You probably do not know that.
Who think that he should be
canonized.
Actually, I was actually
interviewed once about
soliciting my ideas.
I said I hope not because I
want to teach him for what I
think he is a poet,
a man of extraordinary
imagination who divinies our
time.
That's what I think he is,
the power of the imagination,
and who understands that the
greatest call on him and on us
is really the possibility of the
encounter with the Divine.
I don't know--I hate the
idea--if I were to make a movie
about Dante--
I have been--sometimes when
people have been--
I have been mentioning it to
people actually I would make him
into a rebellious type who seems
to understand everything that he
touches,
but he also has a way and
takes, as he should from
everything,
and transforms it,
so he has a vision from that
point of view.
The vision of how the world is
and--he invents the world,
his world, the world of the
Divine Comedy,
it's an extraordinary
invention.
But a saint?
I don't know what these other
guys have done exactly to make
them deserving of sainthood but
maybe I'll leave it there,
I don't know.
Thank you.
I think it's time.
Thank you so much for your
great questions,
thanks.
>